[Music]
you
the Uniform Code of Military Justice
specifies court-martial for any officer
who sends a soldier into battle without
a weapon there ought to be a similar
protection for students because students
shouldn't go out into life without an
ability to communicate and that's
because your success in life will be
determined largely by your ability to
speak your ability to write and the
quality of your ideas in that order I
know that I can be successful in this
because the quality of communication
you're speaking your writing is largely
determined by this formula it's a matter
of how much knowledge you have how much
you practice with that knowledge and
your inherent talent and notice that the
T is very small what really matters is
what you know this point that came to me
uh suddenly a few decades ago when I was
skiing at Sun Valley I had heard that it
was celebrity weekend and one of the
celebrities was a was Mary Lou Retton
famous Olympic gymnast perfect tens of
the vault and I heard that she was a
novice of skiing so when the opportunity
arrived I looked over on a novice slope
and saw this young woman who when she
became unbalanced but like that and I
said that's got to be her that must be
the gymnast but then it occurred to me
I'm a much better skier than she is and
she's an Olympic athlete not only an
ordinary a bullet Olympic athlete an
outstanding one and I was a better skier
because I had decay and I had to pee and
all she had was the tea so you can get a
lot better than people who may have
inherent talents if you have the right
amount of knowledge so that's what my
objective is today adheres my promise
today you will see some examples of what
you can put in your armamentarium of
speaking techniques
and it will be the case that some one of
those examples some heuristic some
technique maybe only one will make what
will be the one that gets you the job
and so this is a very nonlinear process
you never know when it's going to happen
but that is my promise for the end of
the next 60 minutes you know they've
been exposed to a lot of ideas some of
which you'll incorporate into your own
repertoire enable ensure that you get
the maximum opportunity to have your
ideas valued and accepted by the people
you speak with now in order to do that
we have to have a rule of engagement and
that is no laptops no cell phones so if
you could close those I'll start up as
soon as you're done some people ask why
that is a is a rule of engagement and
the answer is we humans only have one
language processor and if your language
processor is inkay could you shut the
laptop please if your language processor
is engaged browsing the web or reading
your email you're distracted and worse
yet to distract all the people around
you studies have shown that and worse
yet if I see a open laptop somewhere
back there or up here it drives me nuts
and I do a worse job and so that ensures
that all of your friends who work there
or who are paying attention don't get
the performance that they came to have
so that's it for preamble
let's get started first thing you talk
about of course is how to start
some people think the right thing to do
is to start a talk with a joke I don't
recommend it
and the reason is that in the beginning
of a talk
people are still putting their laptops
away to becoming adjusted to your
speaking parameters to your vocal
parameters and they're not ready for a
joke so it doesn't work very well they
usually fall flat what you want to do
instead to start with empowerment
promise you want to tell people what
they're going to know at the end of the
hour that they didn't know at the
beginning in the hour
it's an empowerment promise it's the
reason for being here what would be an
example oh I see at the end of this 60
minutes you will know things about
speaking you don't know now and
something among those things you know
will be make a difference in your life
yeah that's an empowerment promise so
that's the best way to start so now that
I've talked a little bit about how to
start what I want to do is give you some
samples of heuristics that are always on
my mind when I give a talk and first of
these heuristics is that it's a good
idea to cycle on the subject go around
it go around it begin go around to begin
some people say so much you want to tell
them tell them again
and then tell them a third time as if
people weren't intelligent but the point
is the reason is well there are many
reasons one of which is in any given
moment about twenty percent of you will
be fogged out no matter what the lecture
is so if you want to ensure the
probability that everybody gets it is
high you need to say it three times so
cycling is one of the things that I
always think about when I give a talk no
thing I think about is in explaining my
idea I want to build a fence around it
so that it's not confused with somebody
else's idea so if you were from Mars and
I was teaching you about what an arch is
I might say to you well that's an arch
and that's not to be confused with some
other things that other people might
think it's not this is not an arch
that's not an arch I'm building a fence
around my idea so that it can be
distinguished from somebody else's idea
so in a more technical sense I might say
well my algorithm might similar might
seem similar to Josie's algorithm except
his is exponential in - linear that's
putting a fence around your idea so that
people can not be confused about how it
might relate to something else
the third thing on this list of samples
is the idea of verbal punctuation and
the idea here is that because people
will occasionally fog out and need to
get back on the bus you need to provide
some landmark places where you're
announcing that it's a good time to get
back on so I might in this talk say
something about this being my outline
the first thing we're going to do is
talk about how to start then we're going
to deal with these four samples and
among these four samples I've talked
about the first idea that's cycling the
second idea building and now the third
idea is built is verbal punctuation some
enumerated and providing numbers I'm
giving you a sense that there's a seam
in the talk and you can get back back on
ok so now we're on a roll and since
we're on a roll can you guess what forth
idea might be here an idea that helps
people get back on the bus
yes ask a question yes thank you so ask
a question and so I will ask a question
how much dead air can there be how long
can I pause I count to seven seconds it
seems like an eternity to me to wait and
not say anything for seven seconds but
that's the standard amount of time you
can wait for an answer
and of course the question has to be
carefully chosen it can't be too obvious
because then people will be embarrassed
to say it what the answer is
can't be too hard because then nobody
will have anything to say so here are
some sample heuristics so you can put in
your armamentarium and build up your
your repertoire of ideas about
presentation and now if this persuade
you that there is something to know that
there there is knowledge then I've
already succeeded because what I want to
convince you of is that if you watch the
speakers you admire and feel are
effective and ask yourselves why they're
successful then you can build up your
own personal repertoire and develop your
own personal style and that's that's my
fundamental objective and the rest of
this talk is about some of the things
that are in my armamentarium that I
think are effective so next thing in our
agenda as we start to discuss these
other things is a discussion of time and
place so what do you think is a good
time to have a lecture 11 a.m. yeah
and the reason is most people that might
er wait by then and hardly anyone has
gone back to sleep it's not right after
a meal
people aren't fatigued from this or that
it's great time to have a lecture so
that brings me next to the question of
what about the place and the most
important thing about the place is that
it be well-lit this room is well-lit
problem with other kinds of rooms is
that we humans
whenever the lights go down or weather
whenever the room is dimly lighted it
signals that we should go to sleep so
whenever I go somewhere to give a talk
even today the first thing I do when I
speak to the are the original people to
say keep the lights full up
oh they might reply people will see the
slides better if we turn the lights off
and then I reply it's extremely hard to
see slides through closed ayahs what
else can you say about the place well
the place should be cased and I mean
that in a cloak Royal sense of like if
you're robbing a bank you would go to
the bank and you know some some
occasions before to see what it's like
so there's no surprises when you when
you do your robbery so whenever I go
somewhere to speak the first thing I
asked my host to do is to take me to the
place where I'll be speaking so there
any weirdnesses I'll be able to to deal
with it sometimes it might require some
intervention sometimes it just might
require me to understand what the
challenges are so when I came here this
morning I did what I typically do I
imagine that all the seats were filled
with disinterested farm animals
that way I knew that no matter how bad
it was it wouldn't be as bad as that so
finally it should be reasonably it
should be reasonably populated it should
be it should be the case that ain't know
if there are ten people in this hall
everyone would be wondering what's going
on that's so much more interesting that
nobody's here so you want to get a right
size place that's doesn't have to be
packed that it has to be more than half
full so those are some thoughts about
time and place the next thing I want to
talk about is subjective the boards and
props and slides
well these are the tools of the trade I
believe that this is the this is a the
right tool for speaking when their
purpose is informing the slides are good
when your purpose is exposing but it's
what I use when I'm informing teaching
lecturing and there are several reasons
why I use it for one thing when you use
the board you have a graphic quality
it's the case that when you have a board
then you can easily exploit the fact
that you can use graphics in your
presentation so that's a graphic quality
that I like and next thing I like is
that like a speed property the speed
with which you write on the blackboard
is approximately the speed at which
people can absorb ideas if you go
flipping through a bunch of slides
nobody can go that fast
finally one great property of a board is
that it can be a target many people who
are now is's speaking find themselves
suddenly aware of their hands it's as if
their hands were private parts that
shouldn't be exposed in public so right
away they go into the pockets and this
is considered insulting in some parts of
the world or alternatively maybe the
hands will go and back like this I was
once in a convent in Serbia and my host
well we were as soon as we entered a nun
came up to us and offered us a
refreshment and I was about to say no
thank you when he said eat that stuff or
die
it's a question of a local custom and
and Colitis but then before anything
happened there the nun pulled my hands
off like this because it was
extraordinarily insulting in that
culture to have your hands behind your
back so why is that well it's it usually
is suppose that that's that it has to do
with whether you're concealing a weapon
such your hands are in your pockets or
behind your back then it looks like you
might have a weapon and that's what I
mean by the virtue of one of these
virtues of the board now you have
something to do with your hands you can
point out the stuff
I was once watching scene where Patrick
gave a lecture I thought it was terrific
so I went a second time first time to
absorb the content second time to note
the style and what I discovered is that
Patrick was constantly pointing at the
board and then I thought about a little
while and I noted that none of the stuff
he was pointing to had anything to do
with what he was saying nevertheless it
was a effective technique so that's just
a little bit about the virtue of black
boards now I want to talk about props
you know the custodians of knowledge
about props are the playwrights many
decades ago I saw play by henrik ibsen
it was head of gambler I remember
vaguely there was about a woman in an
unhappy marriage and her husband was in
competition for an academic job with
somebody else and he was going to lose
partly because he was boring and partly
because the competitor had just written
a magnificent book by the way this is
back in the days before they were
copying machines and computers
anyhow anyhow as the play opens there's
a potbelly stove
and in the beginning of the play the
pot-bellied stove with its open door
just has some slightly glowing embers
but the public stove is always there and
it's tension melts in the play and you
see this manuscript this prop the Ipsen
so artfully use you just know that
something's going to happen because as
the play goes on the fire gets bigger
and hotter and finally all consuming
images know that that manuscript is
going to go into that fire it's
memorable thing is what I remember about
play so playwrights have got this all
figured out but in their hand they're
not the only people who can use props
here's an example of the use of a prop
also due to see more pepper he was
talking about how it's important to look
at the problem in the right way and
here's an example that not only teaches
that that makes it possible for you to
embarrass your friends and Mechanical
Engineering so here's what you do
take this bicycle wheel you started
spinning and then you put some torque on
the axle or equivalently you blow on the
edge and the issue is as we go that way
or does it go that way now the
mechanical engineers will immediately
say oh yes I see right hand screw rule
and they'll put their fingers in this
position but forget exactly how to align
their fingers with various aspects of a
problem and so it's usually the case
that they get it right with about a 50
percent probability
so they're a very fancy education gets
them up to the point where they are
equivalent to flipping a coin but it
doesn't have to be that way because you
can think about the problem a little
differently so here's what you do you
take some duct tape and you put it
around the part of the wheel like that
and now you start to think about not the
whole wheel but just a little piece
that's underneath the duct tape so here
that piece comes rolling over the top at
this point you blow on that with a puff
of air forgetting about the rest of the
wheel what happens to that little piece
is under the duct tape it must want to
go that way but you bang another like
that it's already going down like that
and what about the next piece same thing
next piece same thing so the only thing
that can happen is it the wheel goes
over like that and so now you'll never
wonder again because he's thinking about
the problem in the right way and it's
demonstrated by use of a problem you
could try this after we're done another
example I like to remember is one from
when I was taking 801 Ella Lazarus was
the instructor at the time and he was
talking about the conservation of energy
kinetic and potential and there was a
long wire in a ceiling in 26100 attached
to a much bigger steel ball the one not
one like this and Lazarus took the ball
up against a wall like this he put his
head right against the wall to steady
himself and then he let go and the
pendulum takes many seconds ago over and
back and then gently
kisses Lazarus his nose and so you have
many seconds to think this guy really
believes in the conservation of energy
do not try this at home the problem is
that first time you do this you may not
just let go there's a natural human
tendency to push so that's a little bit
on a subject of props
you know it's interesting whenever
surveys are taken students always say
more chalk less PowerPoint and why would
that be props are always also very
effective why would that be
I'll give you my lunatic fringe view on
this it has to do with what I would call
empathetic mirroring when you're sitting
up there watching me write on the board
all those little mirror neurons in your
head I believe become actuated and you
can feel yourself writing on the
blackboard and even more so when I talk
about this steel ball though I'm not
wearing this way you can you can you can
feel the ball as if you were me and you
can't do that with a slide you can't do
it with a picture you need to see it in
a physical world that's why I think that
oh yes of course it's there their speed
questions involved to that have to be
separated out but I think that
empathetic mirroring is why props and
the use of a blackboard are so effective
well let's see
oh yes there is one more thing by way of
the tools and that has to do with the
use of slides I repeat I think therefore
exposing ideas not for teaching ideas
but that's what we do in a job talk or
conference talk expose ideas we don't
teach them so let me tell you a little
bit about my views on that I remember
once I was some in Terminal A at Logan
Airport I just come back from a really
miserable conference and the flight was
really horrible it was one of those that
feels like an unbalanced washing machine
and for the only time in my life I
decided to stop on my way to my car
and have a cup of coffee and relax a
little bit and as I was there for a few
minutes someone came up to me and said
are you professor Winston I think so I
said I don't know I guess I was trying
to be funny in any event he said I'm on
my way to Europe to give a job talk
would you mind
critiquing my slides not at all I said
you have too many and they have too many
words how did you know he said thinking
perhaps I'd seen a talk of his before I
hadn't my reply was because it's always
true they're always too many slides
always too many words so let me show you
some extreme examples of how not to use
smarts
well for this demonstration I need to be
way over here and that when I get over
here then I can start to say things like
one of the things you shouldn't do is
read your transparencies people in your
audience know how to read and reading
will just annoy them
also you should be sure that you have
only a few words on each transparency
and that their words are easy to read
and I hope it driving you crazy because
I'm committing all kinds of crimes the
first of which is that there are too
many words on the slide second of which
is I'm way over there and the slides way
over there so you get into this tennis
match feeling of shifting back and forth
between the slide and the speaker you
want the slides to be condiments to what
you're saying not the main event or the
opposite way around so how can we fix
this step number one is to get rid of
the background chunk that's always
distraction step number two is to get
rid of the words when I reduced the
words to these then everything I read a
previous time I'm not licensed to say
because it's not on the slide I'm not
reading my slides anymore but I'm saying
what it was written on the slice in a
previous example so what else can we do
to simplify this well we can get rid of
the logos we don't need them
simplification what else can we do get
rid of the title now I want to talk to
you about some rules for slide
preparation I'm telling you the title
doesn't have to be up there by reducing
the number of words on the slide
I mean allow you to pay more attention
to me unless so what's written on the
slide I mentioned it before we have only
one language processor and we can either
use it to read stuff or to listen to the
speaker and so if we have too many words
on the slide forces people in the
audience to redo stuff and not
student of mine did an experiment a few
years ago he taught some students some
web-based programming ideas half the
information was on slides he said the
other half and then for a control group
he reversed it and the question was what
did the subjects that is a freshman in
his fraternity what did the subjects
remember best what he said or what they
read on the slide and the answer is what
they read on the slide when their slides
have a lot of material on it they'll pay
attention to the speaker in fact in the
after-action report one of the subjects
said I wish you hadn't talked so much it
was distracting well the last item is
eliminate clutter I hear some clutter
and we know no reason even for those
bullets so the too many words problem is
a consequence of a crime Microsoft has
committed by allowing you to use some
fonts that are too small so you should
all have a sample slide like this that
you can use to determine what the
minimum font size is this this is easily
legible Shira what do you think of those
what's that
you know minimum maybe you know he says
forty or fifty I think it's about right
thirty-five is if you get too small not
necessarily because you can't read it
but because it because you're probably
using it to get too many words on the
slide
what other crimes do we have well we
have the laser pointer crime meant for
that everyone you know in the old days
when we didn't have laser pointer skis
wooden ones and people would go waving
these things around and pretty soon it
became almost like a baton twirling
contest so here's what his way
recommended in the old days for dealing
with this kind of pointer this example
of use of a prop
Jim glass up there so let's talk about
twenty years ago and so yeah I
remembered that talk that's one way you
broke the pointer
it's amazing how props tend to be the
things that are remembered well now we
don't have we don't have a little
pointers anymore we've got we've got
laser pointers that's a wonder more
people aren't driven into epileptic fits
over this first well here's what tends
to happen
oh yeah that's a lovely recursive
picture and I could become part of it by
putting that laser beam right on the
back of my head up there then what do
you see you see the back of my head and
I have no eye contact no engagement
nothing I was sitting I was a student
watching a talk one day and she said you
know what we could all leave and he
wouldn't know
so what happens when you use the laser
pointer you can't use the laser pointer
without turning your head and pointing
at something and when you do that you
lose you lose contact with the audience
you don't want to do it so what do you
do if you need to identify something in
your image and you don't want to point
out it with a laser this is what you do
put a little arrow on there and say now
look at that guy number one at the end
of arrow number one you don't need to
have a laser pointer to do that
the too heavy crime when people ask me
to review a presentation I asked someone
to print it out and lay it out on a
table when they do that it's easy to see
whether the talk is too heavy
too much text not enough air than the
white space not enough imagery this is a
good example of such a talk way too
heavy now this is the presenter has
taken advantage of small font sizes to
get as much on the slide as he wanted
lots of other crimes here but the two
heaviness the fact that it's too heavy
is what I wanted to illustrate so here
by contrasts another talk when I gave a
few years ago it's not it wasn't a
deeply technical talk but I'll show it
to you because there's air in it it's
mostly pictures of things there are
three or four slides that have text on
them but when I come to those I give the
audience time to read them and they're
there because they might have some
historical significance the first slide
will have text on it as a extraction
from the nineteen fifty-seven from the
for the from the proposal for the 1957
AI conference at Dartmouth
extraordinarily interesting event and
that historical extraction from the
proposal helps drive that point home
what else oh we got here
oh yeah your vocabulary word for the day
this is an app packs legoman on what
that means is this is the kind of slide
you can get away with exactly once in
your presentation this is a slide at
their got some currency some years ago
because it shows the complexity of
governing in Afghanistan by showing how
impossibly complex it is it's something
we you and in the audience can't
understand and that's the point but you
can't have many of these you can have
one per work one for presentation one
for paper one per book that's what I
that's what epic slow going on is and
this is an example of it well I'll show
you some crimes and so you might be
asking do these crimes actually occur so
they do theirs the hands in the pockets
crime there's a crime in time and place
selection here this is how you get to
the Bartos theater first thing you do is
you get on these steps over at the Media
Lab then you cross this large open space
then you turn right down this corridor
at this point whenever I go in there I
wonder if they're torture implements
around the corner and then when you get
in there you get into this dark gloomy
place so it's well-named what when they
call it the Bartos theater because it's
a place where you can watch a movie but
it's not a place where you can give a
talk now on a subjective doesn't happen
here's a talk I attended a while back in
Stata notice that the speaker is far
away from the slides speakers using a
laser pointer and you say to me well
what's happening here is by the way the
80th 80th slide in the presentation
notice that it's dense with words
the first of ten conclusion slides so
what's the audience reaction that's the
sponsor of the meeting he's reading his
email this is the co-sponsor of the
meeting he's examining the lunch menu
[Music]
what about this person this person looks
like he's paying attention but that's
because it's a still picture if you were
to see a video what you would see is
something like this
so yeah it does happen
well now that's a a quick review of
tools now I want to talk about some
special cases I could talk a little bit
about informing or to say another way
doing what I'm doing now but I'll just
say a few words about that and that kind
of in that kind of presentation you want
to start with a promise like I did for
this for this for this hour that we're
going now but then there comes the
question of how do you inspire people
I've given this talk for a long time and
a few years ago our department chairman
said would you please say I give this
talk to a new faculty and be sure to
emphasize what it takes to inspire
students and strangely I hadn't thought
about that question before so I started
a survey I talked to some of my incoming
freshmen advisees and I talked to those
senior faculty and everything in between
about how they've been inspired what I
found from the incoming freshmen is that
they were inspired by some high school
teacher who told them they could do it
when I found in the senior faculty they
were inspired by someone who helped them
to see a problem in a new way and what I
saw from everyone is that they were
inspired when someone exhibited passion
about what they were doing exhibited
passionate about what they are doing
yeah so that's not that's one way to be
inspiring it's easy for me because you
know I do artificial intelligence and
how can you not be interested in
artificial intelligence right I mean if
you're not interested in artificial
intelligence you're probably not
interested in interesting things
so when I'm lecturing in my AI class its
natural for me to talk about what I
think is cool
and how exciting some new idea is so
that's the kind of that's the kind of
expression of passion that makes a
difference while informing with respect
to this question of inspiring oh yeah
and of course during this promise phase
you can also express how cool stuff is
let me give you an example of a lecture
that starts this way I'm talking about
resource allocation it's the same sort
of stuff you would think of when your
source it's the same sort of ideas you
would need if you're allocating aircraft
to a flight schedule or trying to
schedule a factory or something like
that
but the example is putting colors on the
states in the United States without any
bordering states having the same color
so here goes this is what I show in the
beginning of the class this is a way of
doing that coloring and you might say
well why don't we wait till it finishes
would you like to do that no well we're
not going to wait till it finishes
because the Sun will have exploded and
consumed the earth before this program
finishes but with a slight adjustment to
how the program works which I tell my
students you will understand in the next
50 minutes this is what you get isn't
that cool you know you got you got to be
you got to be amazed by stuff that takes
a computation from longer than the
lifetime of the solar system into a few
seconds so that's why I mean by
providing a promise upfront and
expressing some passion about what
you're talking about well the last item
in this little block here is it has to
do with what people think that they do
at MIT you ask faculty what the most
important purpose is and they'll say
well the most important thing I do is
teach people how to think and then
you say oh that's great how do you teach
people how to think blank stare no one
can quite respond to that part that
natural next question so how do you
teach people how to think well I believe
that we are storytelling animals and
that we start developing our story
understanding of manipulating skills
with fairy tales in childhood and
continue on through professional schools
like law business medicine engineering
everything and we continue doing that
throughout life so if that is what
thinking is all about then when you want
to teach people how to think you
provided them with the stories they need
to know the questions they need to ask
about those stories mechanisms for
analyzing those stories ways of putting
stories together ways of evaluating how
reliable the story is and that's what I
think you need to do when you teach
people how to think but that's all about
education and many of you here not
necessarily for that but rather for for
this part for persuading which breaks
down into several categories oral exams
not shown chopped talks getting famous I
won't say much about oral exams other
than the fact that they used to be a lot
scarier than they are today in the old
days reading the literature in a foreign
language was part of that and there was
a high failure rate and when you look at
when you look back on those failures the
most usual reason for people failing an
oral exam is failure to situate and a
failure to practice if I situate I mean
it's important to talk about your
research in context this is the problems
being pursued all over the world
there hasn't been any progress before me
in past 30 years everyone is looking for
a solution because it will have impact
on so many other things
such situating in time and place and
feel and then as far as practice is
concerned but yes practice is important
but that doesn't mean showing your
slides to the people who share an office
with the problem with that is that if
people know what you're doing they will
host Nate that there's material in their
presentation it isn't it isn't there a
very each month seen by the way is your
faculty supervisor is not a very good
person to help you debug a talk because
they in fact know what you're doing and
they will in fact Colusa Nate there's
material in your presentation isn't
there so you need to get together some
friends who don't know what you're doing
and have them well you start the
practice session by saying if you can't
make me cry I won't value as a friend
anymore
and then when you get to the faculty on
a oral exam it will be easy
it's a difficulty or the amount of flack
you'll get from somebody is proportional
to age the older somebody is they're
more the more they understand whether
they are in the world but but the young
people are trying to show the old people
how smart they are so it's a lovely
vicious so whenever you have an
opportunity to have an examining
committee that's full of people with
great hair that's what you want well
that's just a word or two about
something I haven't listened here let's
get into the subject of job talks so I
was sitting at a bar many years ago in
San Diego I was remember the Navy
Science Board and I was saying with a
couple of my colleagues on the board
dolorous editor from the University of
Colorado she made me some jealous I
could spit because she had bitten 21
books and I've only written 17 and then
the other one was Oh bill Weldon from
the University of Texas he was a
electromagnetism guy and you know he
knew how to use railguns to to drive
steel rods through tank armor these are
interesting people so I said what do you
for a faculty candidate and within the
one microsecond Delores said that to
show us they've got some kind of vision
quickly followed by Bill who said they
have to show us that they've done
something know what sounds good I said
and then I said to them how long does
the candidate have to establish these
two things what do you think well
compare your answer to the airs five
minutes so if you haven't expressed your
vision if you haven't told people you've
done something in five minutes you're
are you're are you've already lost so
you have to be able to do that and let
me just mention a couple of things in
that connection here which is you know
the vision is in part a problem that
somebody cares about and something new
in your approach so the problem is
understanding the nature of human
intelligence and the approach is asking
questions about what makes us different
from chimpanzees and Neanderthals is it
merely a matter of quantity or we're
just a little bit smarter in some
continuous way or do we have something
that's fundamentally different that
chimpanzees don't have and Neanderthals
either and the answer is yes we do have
something different we are symbolic
creatures and because we're symbolic
creatures we can we can build symbolic
descriptions of relations and events we
can string them together and make
stories and because we can make stories
that's what makes us different so that's
that's that's my stump speech that's how
I start most of my talks on my own
personal research
how do you express the notion that
you've done something by listening the
steps that need to be taken in order to
achieve the solution of that problem you
don't have to have done all those steps
but you can say here's here's what needs
to be done an example here's what needs
to be done we need to specify some
behavior we need to enumerate the
constraints that make it possible to
deal with that behavior we have to
implement a system because we're
engineers and we don't think that we've
understood something unless we can build
it and we built such a system and we're
about to demonstrate it to you today
that would be an example of a numerating
series of steps needed to realize the
vision so then bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla and then you conclude by you
conclude by enumerating your
contributions it's kind of mirror of of
these steps and helps to establish that
you've done something so that's a kind
of general purpose framework for doing a
technical talk no only a few more things
left to do today getting famous is the
next item on our agenda because once
you've got the job
you need to think a little bit about how
you're going to be recognized for what
you do so
[Music]
Oh first of all why should you care
about getting famous I thought about
this connection with a fundraising event
I attended once fundraising event for
raising money to save Venice from going
underwater and having all of its art
destroyed anyway I was sitting here and
JC was sitting here
that was a Julia CH like Julia Child and
as the evening wore on more and more
people would come up and ask Julia to
autograph something or express a feeling
that she had changed their life and just
happened over and over again so
eventually I turned to Julia and I said
miss child is it fun to be famous and
she thought about it for a second and
she said you get used to it but you know
what occurred to me you never get used
to being ignored so it's you know it's
it's here's a way to think about it your
ideas are like your children you don't
want them to go into the world and rags
so what I wanted to do is to be sure
that you have these techniques these
mechanisms these thoughts about how to
present the ideas that you have so that
they recognize the value that is in them
so that's why it's a legitimate thing to
concern yourself with with packaging now
how do you get remembered well there's
something I like to call Winston Starr
and every one of the items I'm about to
articulate has a starts with an S so if
you want your presentation ideas to be
remembered one of the things you need to
do is to make sure that you have some
kind of symbol associated with your work
so this Arjun example is actually from
my PhD thesis many many years ago and
in the course of my work at that time
this worked on arts learning became
mildly famous and I didn't know why it
was only many years later that I
realized that that work accidentally had
all of the elements on this star so the
first element is that there was a kind
of symbol it's the arts itself next
thing you need is some kind of slogan
a kind of phrase that provides a handle
on the work and in this case the phrase
was one-shot learning and it was
one-shot because the program I wrote
learned something definite from every
example that was presented to us so in
going from a model based on this
configuration to something that isn't an
arts based on that configuration the
program learned that it has to be on top
one-shot learning so that's a simple
slogan and now we need a surprise yeah
the surprise is you don't need a million
examples of something to learn you can
do it with one example if you're smart
enough to make use of that example
appropriately so that was the surprise
you can learn something definite from
each example next item was a salient
idea now when I say salient idea I don't
mean important what I mean is an idea
that sticks out some some theses funnily
enough have too many good ideas and you
don't know what it's all about because
which one is it so you need an idea that
sticks out and the idea that stuck out
here was noticed I'm a near-miss
you see this is not an arch but it
doesn't miss by much so it's a near miss
finally you need to tell the story of
how you did it how it works why it's
important so that's some a bit on how do
not so much get famous but how to ensure
that your work is recognized well doctor
we're almost finished because now we're
down in this last item which is so how
to stop and when we come back there's a
question of alright well what is the
final slide and what are the final words
so for the sign of final slide let me
give you some examples of possibilities
how about this one well you might see
that slide and think to yourself there
are a thousand faculty at MIT nice piece
of work but not so much but it's only a
tiny piece of work if you invited by a
thousand so when you show a whole
gigantic list of collaborators at the
end of a talk it's so kind of it's a
it's it's it's kind of led out because
it suggests that nobody knows whoa did
you do anything significant there you
got it you got to recognize your
collaborators right so where do you do
that
none of the last line on the first slide
all this was on the first slide these
are the collaborators so you don't want
to put them at the end you know what a
slide like this how about this one
this is the worst possible way to end a
talk because this slide can be up there
for 20 minutes I've seen it happen
it's squanders real estate it squanders
an opportunity to tell people who you
are it's just what about this one I
often see it I never seen anybody write
it down
also it wastes opportunity oh my god
[Music]
even worse
all of these slides do nothing for you
they waste an opportunity for you to
tell people to leave people with what
you with who you are well what about
this this is a good one it might seem so
at first but here's the problem if you
say these are my conclusions these are
perfectly legitimate conclusions that
nobody cares about what they care about
is what you have done and that's why
your final slide should have this label
contributions it's a mirror of what I
said over there about how job talks on
to that ought to be like a sandwich and
the final slide the one that's up there
while people are asking questions and
filing out it ought to be the one that
has your contributions on here's an
example from my own stump speech yeah
this is what I talk about a lot yes here
are the things that I typically
demonstrate and I wait for people to
read it and then the final element there
is this is what we get out of it so
that's a sample of a contribution slide
all right now what about the other part
you know you get your final slide up
slide up there is a contribution slide
somehow you have to tell pee
or you're finished so let's say check
out a few possibilities one thing you
could do in the final words is you could
tell a joke it's okay by the time you're
done people have adjusted themselves
your voice parameters they're ready for
a joke I was sitting in another bar this
time in Austin Texas with a colleague of
mine named Doug Lynott and Doug's a
fantastic speaker and so I said to Doug
Doug you're a fantastic speaker what's
your secret
and he said oh I always finished with a
joke and that way people think they've
had fun the whole time so yeah a joke
will work down there how about this one
thank you I don't recommend it so we
move you will not go to hell if you
conclude your talk by saying thank you
but it's a weak move and here's why when
you say thank you
even worse thank you for listening it
suggests that everybody has stayed that
long out of politeness and that they had
a profound desire to be somewhere else
but they're so polite they stuck it out
and that's what you're thinking of
before so what's wild applause that
started you can mal thank you and it's
not there's nothing wrong with that the
last thing you do should not be saying
thank you
how do you say to me well doesn't
everybody say thank you
well what everybody does is not
necessarily the right thing and I like
to illustrate how some talks can end
without saying thank you I like to draw
from political speeches but the ones
that I've heard recently aren't so good
so I'm gonna have to go go back a little
bit so here's a Governor Christie he
gave the Republican keynote address one
year this is the end of his talk let's
see what he does
and together everybody together we will
stand up once again for American
greatness for our children and
grandchildren god bless you and God
bless america
that's on a classic and addiction ending
god bless you bless america now I don't
want to be partisan about this so I
think I better switch to the keynote
address and the Democratic convention
I was delivered that year by by Bill
Clinton who knows something about how to
speak you believe you must vote and you
must really
[Applause]
ooh
now watch this let's go back a little
bit and redo it what I want you to see
is that at one point is he would be
almost pressing his lips together
forcing himself not to say thank you and
then there's another place where he does
a little salute so much for those this
time around
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ezra's person his lips where's the sweet
[Applause]
yeah I think that's pretty good now what
are we gonna take away from this well I
suppose I gave you clued this sock by
saying god bless you and God bless you
that it's the suit of technology but it
might not work so well but what you
can't get out is you don't have to say
thank you well there are other things
you can do and you know it's interesting
that over time people figure this out in
their some stock ways of ending things
so in the Catholic Church and they've
got a Latin Mass let it win it's a this
test which translates approximately to
okay
the mass is over you can go home now and
of course at the musical concerts you
know that it's time to clap not at the
end of the song but rather when the
conductor goes over and shakes hands
with a concert master those are
conventions that tell you that that the
event is over so those are all
possibilities for here but there's one
more possibility and that is that you
can salute the audience and by that I
mean you could say something about how
much you value your time at a place so I
could say well it's been a big fun being
here it's been fascinating to see what
you folks are doing here at MIT I've
been what stimulated and provoked by the
kinds of questions you would ask us been
really great and and I look forward to
coming back many occasions in the future
so that salutes the audience you could
do that
well there it is you know what I'm glad
you're here
and the reason is by being here I think
you have demonstrated an understanding
that how you present and how you package
your ideas as an important thing and I
salute you for that and I suggest that
you come back again and bring your
friends
you
you